patrick is with us in
dallas hey patrick welcome to the dave
ramsey show
thanks for having me dave sure how can
we help
i have um inherited about two and a half
million
in stock after my father passed away
earlier this year
and um yeah i'm sorry i
thank you um it was a big shock but
we've uh
i i i've gotten with a financial planner
and stuff like that
and um basically i guess to align it
with their investment objectives
we're looking at because it was stock
that was from my mother that was in the
trust that was
to him and stuff like that that there's
some capital gains but
it's like 200 000 worth of capital gains
if i'm you know to go with these guys
i've been
talking with but if i you know i keep it
at the bank that it's been invested with
i guess you know nothing's been pulled
out so i don't have any
taxes to pay on it but um i'm just kind
of torn of like
should i keep it where it is should i
you know put it somewhere else with a
another investor
you know somebody watching money a
little bit or something like that i'm
it's just a big number and i you know
i've been thrown in the deep end on this
yeah you sure have how old are you i'm
32.
what's your household income uh 150.
okay well in addition to
the hurt and the broken heart of losing
your dad
uh now you're in the deep end and i hear
i hear both of those things in your
voice
the uncertainty uh there's a certain
amount of fear that goes with this isn't
there
yes yeah i just don't want to do
something wrong i understand
i understand so there's two two ways to
avoid doing something wrong
number one go slow
slow down nothing's on fire
number two do not do anything with money
that you are in charge of unless you
understand it and right now
all you're worried about is did i pick
the right guy
and let me tell you who the guy is the
guy in your mirror
that's the guy and god picked the right
guy
and your dad picked the right guy and
you have the right stuff
you just don't have the right knowledge
yet and as you get more knowledgeable
you're going to be more confident you
remember the first time you ever got
behind the wheel of a car
yeah yeah i do too i was really uh
scared uncertain
and i sucked at driving because it was
the first time i ever did it i threw
gravel all over my dad's house
[Laughter]
okay so uh we really don't want to
put you you know you got thrown behind
the wheel of the car without any driving
lessons right
so just take your time now what you're
looking for
in an advisor is someone who gives
advice
not someone who tells you what to do
they teach
you they need to have the heart of a
teacher
and so then once you understand that you
can say
well i think it's probably worth the 200
000 capital gain to get out of single
stocks which are higher risk
and get over into some mutual funds
where my risk is spread around a little
bit
and you can say that with confidence if
that's what they're looking at i
kind of think that's probably good
advice because they're worried that that
single
stock represents a lot of risk to you
the single stock is much more risky than
being in a mutual fund
with 90 to 200 stocks where if one or
two stocks go up or down it doesn't
destroy you right
and that's why i don't have any single
stocks i only have mutual funds because
by spreading it around
financial people call that diversity you
get safer because you don't have all
your eggs in one basket right now you
got
one at one basket and all the eggs are
in that
right so i kind of think they're leading
you the right way
what i don't like is that they haven't
taught you
because i still hear the uncertainty in
your voice you're not sure you don't
feel it yet you don't feel peace about
it and so you've got to keep
learning until you get peace and it's
okay to let it sit there until you do
okay yeah patrick and that means if it
takes you a year let it sit there
if you want to cash it out just to get
out of single stocks and put it in a cd
i'm okay with that doesn't matter to me
whatever you understand and gives you
some peace
because listen if you mess up 200 2.5
million by 200 000
you're gonna be okay if that's the
biggest mistake you
make you're going to be okay it didn't
destroy the whole fortune right
correct and let's just say it's a
complete error
and you did that now putting it in the
wrong thing
because some slickster
sounded good and was an old family
friend or something
that that that's why you could lose the
whole two and a half million
but you put it in something that someone
taught you
so you understand and that's what you're
doing so
what i would recommend you do is build
yourself a little miniature
advising council a group of people that
you can talk to and you can talk to them
all at once or separately whichever you
want
i would look for an attorney that works
on estate planning
that might be the one that your dad used
because he apparently was using trusts
and other things so he might know what
he's doing
i would look for a cpa someone to be in
my corner on tax issues
and then and they're not investment
counselors although some of the idiots
think they are
okay they're cpas they're bookkeepers
and they're accountants and they do
accounting and taxes they're not
investment advisors
okay and then i would get on
daveramsey.com and click
for tax advice you can find us one of
the cpas that way they'll help you with
that
you can click at daveramsey.com on smart
vester
smart investor pro in your area talk to
a couple of those interview them in
addition to the investment advisor that
you're talking to
and um then you know you go
uh their your job is to find people with
the heart of a teacher
they're going to teach you and that
confidence comes up under you then when
you know
i mean you've experienced this in other
areas of your life patrick where you
didn't know something
and you were uncertain and insecure and
then once you did understand
it gave you a tremendous confidence and
you could throw your shoulders back and
step into it right everything from
learning to drive a car
uh to learning to do whatever your job
is the first day you don't even know
where the bathroom is when you show up
to work right
right it's the same thing man and so
that that you know the uncertainty
means you're wise if you were not
uncertain you would be arrogant
and unwise and dave wouldn't you agree
that was something like this maybe even
find like a mentor that can help him
walk through this process as well
yeah as long as as long as that person
has the heart of a teacher yes
everyone here is teaching you don't want
anyone your corner
selling you or slamming their fists down
and telling you that they're smart and
you're not
those people need to leave you need to
throw them out of your life as soon as
you can
but you're looking i didn't hear anybody
like that in this corner right now
but just make sure that everybody you're
dealing with has the heart of a teacher
and go slow
and don't put money and stuff unless you
you
understand it